une loi déposée par le
gouvernement pour éliminer
l'obligation du serment au roi.
- Le vétéran du caucus péquiste,
à son chef fraîchement élu
le déroulement avant la période
de questions.
- Tout ça est nouveau
pour toi, là.
émotif devant les caméras qui
attend l l l le voir essayer
d'entrer au Salon Bleu.
Joël Arseneau regarde..........
Les travaux débutent en retard
atatatatin, les obligeant
à faire le pied de grue.
Tous les autres élus dûmenttttt
dans le Salon bleu.FRANÇOIS LEG,
premier ministre du Québec
- Moi, je pense que la pri d d r
à aider les québécois à faire
face à l'inflation. Si,
pour le Parti québécois,
il a d'autres pr l l l l l l l .
- Certains ne se gênent pas
pour critiquer le geste
médiatisé du PQ.
ANDRÉ P P P P P P P P P P P P Pc
- Ça m'a pas fait
particulièrement plaisir
de prêter serment au roi,
mo
pour pouvoir siéger, pour
pouvoir débattre, pour que
je puisse aujourd'hui poser des
questions en matière de santé.
parole, Québec solidaire
- C'est à ce moment-là, no
qu'on a fini par décider
de se boucher le nez puis
- On vous sent nerveux,
on vous sent fébrile?
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef du Parti Québécois
geste qui a une signification,
une portée historique.
- Tous les médias veulent voir
ce que fera la sergente d'armes,
gardienne de l'Ass
- En fait, j'ai eu un ordre
clair qui me dvovovovovovous
ne deviez pas rentrer parce que
vous n'avez pas prêté serment.
- Au roi
- La nouvelle présidente,
Na, , , , , , maintient
la décision de son prédécesseur.
La Constitution exige un serment
dédédédédédédédédédédédédédédéde
et sans appel et ne peut êtrese.
- Paul St-Pierre Plamondon n'a
d'autre choix que de tourner
- On fait avancer les choses.
En l'espace d'une semaine
seulement, on a réussi à rallier
tous les partis politiques
pour que ça change. Hier,
dit qu'il voulait que ça change.
- À l'intérieur, lessssss
ont brillé par leur absence.uéu,
ce matin, son projet de loipopo.
Le gouvernement déposera
le sien la semaine prochaine,
pressés de l'adopter et
faire entrer plus vite leurs
adversaires au Salon bleu?
Radio-Canada, Québe